a large amount of 20th century art was
made for the museums they needed to be
though you need at very large spaces in
which you could host a Rothko or a
Jackson Pollock or whatever 13th century
painting was made for the church it's
not made for the museum's
do you think the future of art and let
me just cast you as an artist man the
future of art now is going outside the
museum again as it once was
yeah I mean I think the museum is is you
know traditionally a space of
collections a Contemporary Art Gallery
is a sort of reflection of the art of
the time but there's always been as you
say many spaces outside of the museum or
the gallery which are spaces of kind of
art display and production so like I'm
particularly interested in different
forms of public art I think there's and
also in how an art centers can be spaces
of production so don't have people of
familiar with places like Drysdale or
wise in art centers but those both -
uk-based
art centers where really there's a
there's a much greater emphasis on those
spaces of production as opposed to just
spaces of sort of visual consumption I
think that's a really interesting
direction for art spaces to take I'm
also in organizations like situations in
Bristol there are a public art
production company and they've just
written a kind of a new set of rules for
what they think public art should be and
it and I think and I think how arts can
kind of how art mixes with everyday life
I mean is critically important I think
it's going to continue to be a space
where there's kind of a lot of emerging
art practice do you think patrons and
the patrons of this public art are often
local bodies city wide body sometimes
they're national bodies sometimes they
are the Arts Council do you think that's
the way patronage will work because
because even the British Museum now is
only 50% funded by the public and I
remember speaking to martin wroath
blessing
who's died who was the director of VNA
and he and I work to take the VNA to
China and he said stop using the word
public Phillip oh he doesn't mind
wherever he is that I'm telling this
story he said stop using the word public
Phillip all the word private about
museums he said no museums are public
now no museums are private all museums
are entrepreneurial the truth is the
private for good and for bad is driving
a lot of change if the 20th century was
an an era of kind of public the 21st
century increasingly looks like and they
were a private patronage yeah and it's I
mean but it's always been so if you go
to the arena chapel in padua and you see
giotto's masterpieces they are because a
very rich man paid him to do it it's
always been private has always been an
artist I've always been entrepreneurial
Gainsborough set up his studio and his
sister had a hat shop underneath so that
he could say to people coming in to have
their portraits painted oh your hat is a
bit out of date why don't you go
downstairs and then they would share the
profits it's always been so you have to
be entrepreneurial in this in the
museum's haven't always been private I
mean that I mean what Phillip is is
talking about is there is a clear shift
I don't know how far it will go
certainly you know when I first worked
in the in the art sector which was 1985
almost all money for museums galleries
etc came from the government and they
over the last 40 years that's that's
changed considerably for modder bates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute's of Arts and ideas at AI
TV
you